foreign
[Music]
News at 10 live from the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev our top story
Putin's war is failing Biden sends a
strong message to the Kremlin on a
surprise visit to Keith
Putin thought Ukraine was weak
and the West Was divided
as you know Mr President I said to you
in the beginning he's counting on us
not sticking together
the White House reveals it told Moscow
ahead of the visit but no reaction yet
from the Kremlin
it's the factories in the U.S ramping up
ammunition production to send to Keith
[Music]
also tonight please confirm the body
found in the river wire is that of
missing mother of two Nicola bully
we will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special
[Music]
the families of five people shot dead in
Plymouth accused the police of giving
the gunman a license to Kill
and Junior doctors in England vote to
strike for 72 hours in March we speak to
one Doctor Who wants to leave the NHS
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good
evening we're live in Kiev on a day when
the West put on a show of strength and
unity side by side with Ukraine earlier
today the U.S President Joe Biden
arrived here to meet his counterpart
Vladimir zielinski a huge Security
operation ensued fueling rumors that the
U.S president would be coming here and
then pictures of the two presidents at
one point laying Reeves at a memorial in
the capital as air raid sirens sounded
around them the symbolic visit comes on
the week that marks one year since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and Biden
said the U.S support would not waver
tonight we'll report from here in
Ukraine from Moscow and from the U.S Sky
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes is here in Kiev and has tonight's
first report
a moment of history in the heart of Kiev
what a pleasure how are the children Joe
Biden all smiles but this trip took
serious risk
Vladimir zelensky shows his most
important of VIPs around
his top team Keen to say hello they
asked me how many times I've been here I
had to count even my eighth time well
it's never enough I'm looking for a
passport
wartime leaders wanting to show a united
front this is so much larger than just
Ukraine
it's about freedom and democracy in
years
the pair emerged from a private meeting
with Mr Biden announcing new pledges of
Military Support worth half a billion
dollars
Putin thought Ukraine was weak
and the West Was divided
but he's just been plain wrong
plain wrong
and one year later the evidence is right
here in this room
we stand here together
the visit by the president of the United
States to Ukraine the first in 15 years
is the essential visit of the entire
history of Ukraine U.S relations
precisely in this period because this
period is the most difficult
it's a moment that won't be forgotten
look even lockdown the two presidents
toured a landmark monastery
a moment of reflection
[Music]
a reminder of the war
to the echo of an air raid siren they
walked to a wall where Ukraine's war
dead are remembered both paid their
respects
a brief but bold encounter
it's amazing
yes and he is big boss you know
coming just ahead of the first
anniversary of Russia's full-scale
Invasion this trip appears designed to
send a clear message to Vladimir Putin
that Ukraine is still standing strong
and the United States will stand
alongside it for as long as it takes but
as the Memorial Wall illustrates the
cost already paid by this country has
been huge and the war has no end in
sight
the U.S president will be all too aware
his ability to stay the course in
Ukraine has only just begun to be tested
Deborah Haynes Sky News Kiev
as Deborah was saying this war seems a
long way from being over as we approach
a year since the start of the invasion
let's just take a look at how things
have unfolded on the first day of the
war cities across Ukraine were attacked
by Russian forces one month into the war
Russia controlled large areas of
Ukraine's eastern border and was
attempting to make land passages between
our strategic areas a year into the war
Ukraine has managed to reclaim some
regions previously held by Russia the
Russian offensive continues to have a
large front line in the donbass region
in eastern Ukraine it's believed the new
Russian spring offensive will attempt to
push further westwards across the
donbass and in the north from zafarisha
over the weekend Ukrainian troops
conducted exercises in the town of
seversk north of back moot a potential
Target and it's thought Russia might set
up other lines of attack like Kiev to
make it harder for Ukraine to
concentrate its forces
well a visit by Joe Biden was tightly
controlled but it was revealed that the
White House had notified Moscow that
Biden would be in Kiev today Sky's
Moscow correspondent Diana magnet
reports now on the Russian response
50 minutes
dissing Joe Biden's trip to Key a host
Olga Cabela asks if Russia guaranteed
his safety and if so why
we could have killed Biden but that
would have been too much her guest
replies
we spoke to Sergey Markov a one-time
advisor to President Putin just after he
came off the show
with Russia before the visit to avoid
nuclear war it was about not killing
John president of United States Joe
Biden from Russian rocket missiles
um if you uh this would have meant
potential nuclear war if anything had
happened to him
uh he has one of the possibility of the
killing president of United States or
president of Russia that this can lead
to the uh nuclear war
no comment yet from the Kremlin but this
is a week pact with presidential
speeches there is plenty of time and
these pictures will be spun to further
the kremlin's narrative that Ukraine
does Joe Biden's bidding and that the
Real Enemy here is the United States
no doubt the symbolism of this trip is
not lost on Vladimir Putin but unlike
this time a year ago he understands now
there is no quick win to this war he's
seen the shape of Ukrainian bravery and
of its allies resolve in money and tanks
and sanctions and it hasn't stopped him
yet
China's top Diplomat was in Hungary
today ahead of a trip to Moscow the
Kremlin says he may meet the president
after the U.S warned China against
supplying military aid to support
Putin's war effort China has not so far
but if it does this terrible war in
Europe could become more dangerous still
Donna magnet Sky News Moscow
well during President Biden's visit to
Kiev today it was revealed that the
United States would be providing 500
million dollars in extra Aid including
military assistance well in the U.S
itself Sky News has visited an
ammunitions Factory which has expanded
its production to a level not seen since
the Korean War Skies Mark Stone reports
now from Scranton in Pennsylvania
it is an unlikely place to find
Ukraine's war effort in full swing
in the bowels of a former Railway plant
five thousand miles from the
battlefields
American Steel Workers producing round
after round of artillery
we're on the production line of a
century-old factory
an industry that had been dismissed as
obsolete
now in overdrive
this robot will operate in this
environment all day every day
tour offered to Sky News is an attempt
to show that the production line is fine
that the West is not running out of
ammunition there's a surge in in
production we're working and as hard as
we need to work to
the requirements of the contract you
know we're working probably two shifts
every day solid five six days a week
also preparing you know to increase
production incrementally
none of the officials will mention
Ukraine itself language is carefully
controlled contracts and meeting demand
but the contract is Ukraine and the
demand is huge
eleven thousand rounds now roll off this
line each month and yet it's not nearly
matching what Ukraine's Army is using
The Entity of the war in Ukraine the
military there is firing off between
five and seven thousand of these
artillery shells every single day and
that's why the U.S military is investing
two billion dollars so ramp up
production of facilities like these
this Factory alone is getting 240
million dollars to modernize because
Russia has spooked the West a mechanical
War of the type they thought was in the
past it's firing up old factories and
old rivalries
Russia is obviously the wrong and we're
doing the right formed by supporting
the pre-ukraine just-in-time supply
chain is breaking down and stockpiles
are shrinking but simply it's a race
against Russia to rearm it's expensive
important safety standards slow the
process and this is the easy part
because from here they're shipped a
thousand miles west to Iowa where
they're filled with explosives and fuses
are fitted and then to Ukraine
this surge in activity reflects the new
fragile reality hollowed out Western
stockpiles and the threat of Continental
conflicts
Mark Stone Sky News in Scranton
Pennsylvania
let's go live now to Warsaw in Poland
President Biden's next stop after Kiev
our International Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn is there and Dominic tomorrow A
Tale of Two speeches President Biden in
Warsaw and President Putin in Moscow
yeah very well put Mark I think we've
got live pictures of shop our airport
just outside of Warsaw where we are
expecting Air Force One to arrive
bringing the American president after
his Epic Journey from uh where you are
due to arrive just about now so running
a little bit late now ahead of that one
of his officials said that Joe Biden had
felt that he had a mission to undertake
uh by going to Kiev that he wanted to do
so he can retire tonight confident that
mission that mission is accomplished the
day's been compared by some to some of
the memorable moments of the Cold War
the ich bin Berliner speech for instance
at JFK John F Kennedy gave in Berlin
West Berlin in 1963 or the speech in
1987 where Ronald Reagan urged Mr
Gorbachev to tear down that wall what we
haven't heard is the kind of rhetorical
oratory to match so those moments
although some people say just by going
there we've had a moment just as
memorable but the American president has
a chance tomorrow to find the words to
fit the moments to fit the momentous
time that we're in now that's this
pivotal moment as we move into a second
year that the war and he has that chance
when he gives his speech in The Gardens
of the royal castle here in Warsaw
tomorrow afternoon ahead of that he's
got a meeting with Andre Duda the Polish
president and the next day he's going to
meet the leaders of the Bucharest nine
those are the central European nations
closest to Russia they are projecting
unity and solidarity but behind that
there is still this tension between
those who want to give the ukrainians
everything they need now in a military
sense to finish the war off as soon as
possible before it spreads to other
nations as world leaders have been
warning us this week or draws in China
as the Americans have been warning about
as well and those on the other side who
say give the ukrainians too much they
may go too far they may corner of
Vladimir Putin and he may escalate The
War Out of desperation and I think so
behind the projection of strength
resolve and unity we've seen today and
we'll see in the coming days there is
that tension in the positions between
the Allies attention I think that the
president and his allies will want to
try and resolve as we move into a second
year of this war
okay Dominic thanks very much indeed and
on that very issue tonight the former
prime minister Liz truss has called for
military aircraft to be sent to Ukraine
speaking from the back benches and
echoing a call from her predecessor
Boris Johnson Liz truss said it's an
essential move to help Ukraine win the
war
we need to do all we can as fast as we
can my view is that does include fighter
jets and we've had a discussion today
about which are the best possible
options
having spoken to the ukrainians about
this months and months ago I know what
they want is an option they want so
let's work with our allies to get them
an option to be able to use because
otherwise they won't be able to prevail
also in the UK the King has visited
Ukrainian military recruits uh bringing
uh being trained rather in Wiltshire
many of the 200 recruits are civilians
who have no previous military experience
they are being taught the basics of
combat during a four-week course
well there we are Anna it's been a quite
remarkable day here and tomorrow these
two big speeches from President Putin
and President Biden back to you
mark thank you
family and friends of Nicola bully
finally had confirmation today that the
body recovered from the river wire
yesterday is that of the missing mother
of two the 45 year old disappeared while
walking her dog in Sir Michael's armoire
more than three weeks ago her body was
found about one mile away from where she
was last seen Skye's insomam Rasheed
reports and a warning this report
contains flash photography
it took 24 days to find her and it was
the news nobody wanted to hear
the mum of two whose face has been
painted Across the Nation for the last
three weeks was indeed the body police
recovered from the river wire we are now
now able to confirm that yesterday we
recovered Nicola Bully from the river
wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated today's
development is not the outcome any of us
would have wanted
and a family heartbroken said this we
will never be able to comprehend what
Nikki had gone through in her last
moments and that will never leave us
we will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special and nothing will cast a shadow
over that and then criticism of the
media and the way it has reported on the
investigation it saddens us
think that one day
to them that the Press
and members of the public
accuse their dad of wrongdoing
misquoted and vilified friends and
family
this is absolutely appalling
they have to be held accountable this
cannot happen to another family
we tried last night to take in what we
have been told in the day
only to have
Sky News
and ITV making contact with us directly
when we expressly asked for privacy
they again have taken it upon themselves
to run stories
about us to sell papers and increase
their own profits
it is shameful
they have acted in this way
leave us alone now
their pain wasn't helped by three long
weeks of extensive searches including
divers boat scouring the Riverbanks and
high-tech sonar equipment there was no
sign of the 45 year old they all failed
to locate her in the end it was two dog
walkers that found Nicola it was along
this stretch of River where police
retrieved Nicola's body a mile
Downstream from where her phone her dog
Willow and its lead were discovered but
finding her isn't the end of this
investigation police are trying to piece
together how and why she ended up here
a 10-minute window of Nicholas movements
around this bench remains unaccounted
for it could be a mystery that may never
be resolved
but Lancashire police will need to
provide answers to the very top of
government I did have concerns earlier
in the week about some of the elements
really relating to the release of
personal information of Nicola bully
into the public domain I raised those
concerns with the chief Constable I
wasn't wholly satisfied I have to say
with some of the responses I got
in the village of Saint Michael's the
last three weeks will have felt like
time has stood still a small quaint
Community now dealing with great loss
and pain into man Rashid Sky News
Lancashire
families are victims of a mass shooting
in Plymouth said today that the gunman
Jake Davidson had been granted a license
to Kill after the police ignored
warnings about him the coroner ruled
that the five victims were unlawfully
killed a warning this report from Dan
Whitehead shows footage of a separate
attack on members of the public carried
out by Jake Davidson
leaving home after killing his mother
with a loaded shotgun he should never
have had
in August 2021 Jake Davidson strolled
the streets of Plymouth killing his
victims at random
they included three-year-old Sophie
Martin and her father Lee along with
Davidson's mother Maxine 59 year old
Stephen Washington and 66 year old Kate
Shepard
captured on CCTV with a gun under his
chin
Davison then took his own life
18 months on an inquest Jury has found
how Devin and Cornwall police made
catastrophic failures in granting
Davidson a shotgun certificate which the
victim's family say was essentially a
license to Kill we will never be able to
understand or comprehend why Davidson
did what he did
it was an act of Pure Evil
however
we now know that this evil at was
facilitated and enabled by a series of
failings and incompetence from the
people and organizations
that are supposed to keep us safe
when 22 year old Davison applied for a
shotgun license he declared his autism
and Asperger's but police failed to get
information from his GP in September
2020 he brutally attacked a teenager in
a skate park police investigating didn't
know he had a shotgun license the
officer was unaware FC on the police
database meant firearm certificate his
weapon was eventually taken away but
despite his history of violence and the
fact his mother had tried to refer him
to the anti-terrorism prevent scheme his
gun was handed back just five weeks
before his shooting spree damn deeply
sorry for the loss of those families and
for the feelings and my force that led
to Jack Davis and having a gun where he
shouldn't have the force says the
application process for a firearms
license has been reformed but the issues
highlighted in this inquest are more
far-reaching this is not just about
failures in one force the jury also
found that a lack of training for
firearms licensing officers was
Nationwide putting Public Safety at risk
the police Watchdog the iopc has issued
a series of recommendations to
strengthen Firearms licensing but for
the victims families this is yet again a
case of too little too late
damn Whitehead Sky News in Exeter
another powerful earthquake has struck
turkey's hate Province tonight measuring
6.4 magnitude tonight's earthquake
centered around the town of Daphne and
was followed by a 5.8 Aftershock initial
reports that at least three people have
been killed in more than 200 injured as
more buildings collapsed the same area
was devastated by the massive earthquake
more than two weeks ago which killed
more than 47 000 people
Scotland's Finance Minister Kate Forbes
has said she will stand to succeed
Nicholas dirchen as first Minister her
confirmation came as Angus Robertson the
smp's former Westminster leader ruled
himself out of the leadership contest
Nicholas sturgeon said today she won't
be endorsing any candidate it's now for
the SNP members to scrutinize and
evaluate the competing candidates and
make their choice I am not going to pass
comment on any individual candidate I'm
not going to endorse anyone I don't
think that would be fair or appropriate
I've got one vote the same as every
other SNP member but what I'd say to all
of the candidates in the race and the
person who ultimately succeeds is my
door will always be open should they
want to have my advice or or my
perspective from my years of experience
as first minister
Junior doctors will follow other health
workers and strike for 72 hours next
month in a dispute overpay 98 of those
who voted back the move the British
Medical Association said doctors were
frustrated and angry one Junior doctor
has told Sky News that the NHS system is
broken disguise people and politics
correspondent Nick Martin reports
so here we are at the
yeah I do most of my shift here in a e
this is Alessia Waller a junior doctor
working in the NHS but she's had enough
it can be easy to forget that you're in
a world-class tertiary Center and just
feel like you're in the trenches
the NHS is facing the greatest Workforce
crisis in its 74-year history doctors
like Alessia say they're being driven
Away by a toxic mix of poor working
conditions and poor pay after just nine
months in the job she says she was burnt
out signed off work I just hated going
to work
I hated
um
being at work I didn't feel like I was
doing my job well anymore
I was just disconnected and
disillusioned with
everything what does it tell us about
the system the NHS that you needed to
step out I think it shows that the
system is not fit for purpose and that
um
it is past Breaking Point
Junior doctors have now voted in favor
of strike action which means they'll
join nurses and ambulance staff in a
walkout which will place intense
pressure on the NHS what they've seen is
a sequence of below inflation pay Rises
so they've seen their pay in relative
terms Fall by about 26 since 2008 and
that's really difficult for them you
know they're not worth a quarter less
than they were in 2008
the department for Health and Social
care says there are record numbers of
doctors working in the NHS but that
doesn't tell the full story a record
number are resigning too
3229 doctors resigned from the NHS in
England last year and the number of
doctors leaving has accelerated rapidly
since the pandemic last year almost 13
000 doctors in the UK gave up their
license that's up by nine percent on the
year before
yeah Alessia looks likely to add to that
she's planning to move to the United
States to pursue her dream of becoming a
surgeon the NHS can no longer offer me
the training that I need or want
I don't feel valued I don't feel
supported and
I think I might have a better chance
somewhere else
the department for Health and Social
care says vacancies are increasing
because services are expanding to tackle
waiting lists post covid
but the NHS is now in a perilous
position with record numbers of workers
planning to walk out as discontent
spreads Nick Martin Sky News
take you straight to pictures uh on in
Warsaw here is Air Force One uh the U.S
president departing his plane as you can
see flew from Southeastern Poland after
another 10 hour train journey back
across Ukraine after that surprise visit
heading into the Center of Warsaw where
he will make an address tomorrow
afternoon from The Gardens of the royal
castle there after a meeting with the
Polish president Andres Judah and the
Bucharest nine the central European
nations closest to Russia all part of
this visit to Poland which was scheduled
the part that was unscheduled of course
the visit to Ukraine are the pictures of
him with President zielinski seeing
those photos of the Dead in the
Ukrainian war and that's significant
visit today to the Ukrainian capital